niemand kennt seinen namen niemand weiß
woher er kommt vielleicht aus liberia
vielleicht aus mali er wollte nach
europa er wollte ein besseres leben
der strom von menschen die zuflucht
suchen in europa will nicht abreißen die
methoden krimineller schlepperbanden
werden immer brutaler
europas umgang mit den flüchtlingen
immer erbärmlicher
das system wie wir asylrecht gewähren
ist verrückt wir sagen eigentlich die
muss zuerst die russisches roulette
spielen du musst tausende dollar
aufbringen du musst es auf ein boot
schaffen und er ist vielleicht dabei
ertrinken wenn das schaffen einen fuß
auf einen strand zu setzen dann hören
wir dich an das macht doch keinen sinn
man nennt es ein menschenrecht aber
eigentlich ist es ein grausames um licht
17.000 menschen sind im mittelmeer
drücken aufgrund dieser struktur oder
versuchung und dabei erreichen wir die
hilfsbedürftig sind nicht einmal weil
die menschen die asyl am dringendsten
brauchen ist nicht zu uns schaffen
exodus das neue buch des weltweit
renommierten ökonomen paul kolja bringt
sprengstoff zum thema einwanderung denn
kolja fordert angesichts der
menschlichen katastrophe an europas
grenzen ein radikales umdenken eine neue
politik
ich habe lange gezögert dieses buch zu
schreiben weil die debatte so vergiftet
und polarisierend ist
es ist eine debatte unter gehörlosen
people die leute schreien sich
angebliche wahrheiten ins gesicht
anstatt ein gemeinsames verständnis zu
suchen das auf erkenntnis und analyse
basiert kommen
deswegen habe ich gezögert in dieser
debatte zu intervenieren
und ich bin immer noch sehr ins wie
später bis gut war das buch überhaupt zu
schreiben
seine thesen provozieren weil er kühl
und nüchtern nur die realität analysiert
in der ideologisch und emotional hoch
gebauten debatte um migration
er schlägt vor einwanderer die europa
illegal erreichen zurückzuschicken nur
so könne verbrecherischen
schlepperbanden das handwerk gelegt
werden
stattdessen ein einwanderungssystem für
ganz europa mit klaren regeln quoten und
anlaufstellen für anträge in den
herkunftsländern
und er will dass den ärmsten ländern der
welt endlich so geholfen wird dass
auswanderung dort kein thema mehr sein
wird asyl soll es nur für die geben die
politisch rassisch oder religiös
verfolgt werden
die richtige frage die man auf werfen
muss ist nicht ob emigration gut ist
oder schlecht sondern wie viel
einwanderung für eine gesellschaft sinn
macht diese antwort will aber niemand
hören weil die gesellschaft im moment
aufgeteilt ist in diejenigen die
einwanderung wunderbar finden und jene
die ein wandel und christliche
botschaft dass ein wenig einwanderung
besser ist als gar keine dass man sowohl
zu viel einwanderung wie auch zu wenig
haben kann diese für mich sehr robuste
wahrheit will keine seite akzeptieren
dass die ergebnisse seiner forschung je
nach politischer richtung mal so oder
mal so ausgelegt werden dagegen kann er
sich nicht mehr im spiegel lesen sich
seine thesen anders als in der
konservativen zürcher weltwoche
doch rassismus lehnt er ab denn paul
koller ist selber nach fahrer eines
einwanderers
mein großvater verließen dorf ernst bach
ging nach bradford heiratete eine
engländerin und dann bekannte erste
weltkrieg
sein großvater gerät als deutscher in
england zwischen die fronten wird als
spion denunziert und angegriffen
er musste seine frau und seine kinder
darunter meinen vater mit einer
eisenstange vor einer rassistischen
heute beschützen
meine familie hat erlebt was es heißt
opfer von rassismus zu sein von einer
stimmung gegen einwanderer
das ist in der seele meiner familie
tiefe wurzeln
wollen wir nie wieder erleben
deshalb muss immigration so stattfinden
können dass die gesellschaft eine
schrittweise integration verkraften kann
dann wird sie all die einwanderer als
überwiegend positiven beitrag zur
gesellschaft akzeptieren
wer sich ernsthaft und ohne ideologische
vorbehalte mit dem elend an europas
grenzen auseinandersetzen will kommt an
paul collins buch nicht vorbei und an
seiner forderung nach einer anderen
neuen und gemeinsamen politik der
einwanderung nach europa